welcome to this video playing Bob Hawke
park no name but it's got a doc oops
what am I doing here see the dog okay so
let's see probably get some kind of
Queens Indian know we can catch holy
yeah that's a line that I've got they
have her play down numerous times
already so what's going for this 96 okay
ah of course the saucer at the end of 96
rather stupid simply forgot about this
idea that you can do this
I've how awful
okay maybe I have to try this now and
try to disturb him here a little bit
night p7s knight c6 and if I can take on
a six that point is dangerous me maybe I
haven't planned this of course if if it
does work out somehow miraculously it is
just luck yeah that's a good move
however hmm but f5 if there's s Quincy
to
what a disaster of a game unbelievable
and a d3 check probably win for black
but it's not that I had many many good
alternatives 93 check txtx Queenie 724
check and black ass better but question
is so where do i go to have to crawl
check right at least it doesn't feel
like swoop assembled to win so probably
some way to to screw this up ok quindi 6
try to limit us night
I get in rook t2 i can actually threaten
the b5 porn it's not not that easy this
position so yeah well is still not able
to move move the size pieces from I can
take 9 26 27
quite remarkable yeah that must be
pretty frustrating for him I played
played that like a [ __ ] but somehow he
it wasn't he didn't punish me for that
so yeah 95 I'm not sure I can go native
three-year to 192 months also good news
maybe maybe well look back don't want
that notified you can take play 97 this
is what I'm not liking about it maybe
just here
hmm poor wanted to call night rookie to
a 95 but that's not working
time warning fruit I don't see a good
move now
I can take with the Queen how stupid is
that I thought you had to chain with a
pawn at least a very come on what a
terrible game amazing that was amazingly
bad game by me check not sure why you
went into the self pin I'm not
threatening much to be perfectly honest
check this I'm threatening just pushing
the air horn okay check check check mate
that's kind of fitting into the game
there was simply terrible my god what a
bad game yeah first I'm overlooking be
five which is kind of sad now okay I
felt that this is the relatively best
chance otherwise I'm just losing c44 not
much t8 at least looks kind of
complicated okay he found that move I
went here and now here yeah I guess I
members of course after you for that I
didn't see any relative I are here
knight c6 is strong that's a very strong
move by the engine because this is check
pretty awful so I have to go here yeah
yeah this is a much much better version
I know he has got this at this is
winning right away yeah okay there's no
surprise that that was
kind of loss here I think I'm kind of
okay I mean this night cannot move and I
even even got this pawn bag o Queen h1
now was winning oh so let's let's go
back where was the mistake I think here
and that wasn't bad okay rook c8 I
shouldn't have allowed the engine gives
this move okay preventing whoopsie eight
if here Quincy six night before no I ok
answer this is a bad idea you're ugly
too yeah i can get a king or queen h1
and i can resign with the clear
conscience no it's ok again and I should
go Queenie five yeah I probably should
but yet I didn't like it I mean here ok
the engine just says equal him yeah
probably have to do that Jared here I'm
just losing I'm just losing yeah there
were multiple ways probably to win yeah
but it was a bit weird that he that he
put himself into this here now white is
better not that much but so what what
should you have done a good you one here
in two wins now he's got a pawn and the
better structure so can't get here i'm
completely when he already had with a
pawn amazing check and check and i
couldn't come on checkmate Oh terrible
game but yeah very lucky very lucky okay
thanks for watching